Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. How should we remember Cleopatra? A pretty young temptress rolling out of a carpet? A mighty queen sailing majestically down the Nile? An imperious pharaoh with the power of life and death? Or simply a girl born into a dangerous world who managed to survive for almost four decades until her luck finally ran out. There's an element of truth in all of them. More than 2,000 years after she was born, she remains the most famous woman in history, a fighter, a survivor, a leader, a legend.
感谢您收听《历史其余部分》（The Rest Is History）。想要获取每周独家加更节目、无广告收听体验、系列节目的抢先收听权限，以及加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区的会员资格，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。我们该如何铭记克娄巴特拉（Cleopatra）？是一个从地毯里滚出来的美丽年轻妖精？是一艘在尼罗河上雄伟航行的强大女王？是一个掌握着生杀大权的专制法老？还是一个出生在危险世界里、设法生存了近四十年直到好运最终耗尽的普通女孩？这其中都有真实的成分在她身上。在她出生两千多年后，她依然是历史中最著名的女性、一个斗士、一个幸存者、一个领袖、一个传奇。
For centuries to come, people will remember her story. And that, you might say, was her greatest victory. That is the ending of a top new book on Cleopatra, Queen of the Nile, by a very distinguished historian, Dominic Sandbrook. Dominic, this is the latest in your series of books written for younger readers. It is indeed, yes, The Latest Adventure in Time. So Cleopatra was an obvious one to pick for kind of 8- to 12-year-olds because they, like the rest of us, are suckers for – I mean, suckers is the wrong word. They, like the rest of us, are enthusiasts for glamour, intrigue, battles.
在未来的几个世纪里，人们仍会铭记她的故事。你可以说，这正是她最伟大的胜利。这是一本关于尼罗河女王克娄巴特拉的全新顶级图书的结局，作者是杰出的历史学家多米尼克·桑德布鲁克（Dominic Sandbrook）。多米尼克，这是你为年轻读者撰写的系列图书中的最新一本。确实如此，是的，这是《时间中的最新冒险》（The Latest Adventure in Time）。所以克娄巴特拉是一个显而易见的选择，适合大概 8 到 12 岁的孩子，因为他们和我们其他人一样，都对——我的意思是，“好骗”这个词不对。他们和我们其他人一样，都是迷人风情、阴谋诡计和战争的爱好者。
Gold. Sieges, gold. Yeah. Glitter. Sphinxes, all thathinxes all that you know yeah doom love affairs all the things that we associate with ancient egypt with ancient rome and particularly with the character of cleopatra so people who've listened to this um podcast on a regular basis may remember that we also did an episode on alexander the great uh and the reason that we did an episode on alexander the great is because um your previous book in this series was on alexander yeah um and in in the end of that book you offered up alexander the great as a model for for young children everywhere and we've got a question here from um judith downey who says i bought dominic's book on
黄金。围城战，黄金。是的。闪亮之物。狮身人面像，所有这些，你知道的，是的，末日，风流韵事，所有那些我们与古埃及、古罗马特别是与克娄巴特拉这个人物联系在一起的事物。所以，经常收听这个播客的人可能会记得，我们也做过一期关于亚历山大大帝的节目，呃，我们做亚历山大大帝这期节目的原因是因为呃你在这个系列中的上一本书就是关于亚历山大的，是的。而且在那本书的结尾，你把亚历山大大帝作为各地儿童的榜样提了出来。我们这里有一个问题，来自呃朱迪思·唐尼（Judith Downey），她说：“我买了一本多米尼克写的关于
cleopatra for my granddaughters before i give it it to them, can you tell me, is Cleopatra a role model for girls? I think she absolutely is a role model for girls, Tom. I don't think role models for girls need to be drippy. And I think Cleopatra is the most famous example in history of a powerful woman. So there aren't that many historical examples of very, very powerful, internationally famous women. I suppose Catherine the Great is an obvious one. Elizabeth I in England. But Cleopatra dwarfs both of those.
克娄巴特拉的书送给我的孙女们，在我把书交她们之前，你能告诉我，克娄巴特拉是女孩们的榜样吗？”我认为她绝对是女孩们的榜样，汤姆。我不认为女孩们的榜样必须是那种软弱无力的。而且我认为克娄巴特拉是历史上最有权势女性的最著名例证。因此，历史上并没有那么多非常非常强大且国际闻名女性的例子。我想叶卡捷琳娜大帝是一个显而易见的例子。英格兰的伊丽莎白一世。但克娄巴特拉的成就让这两位都黯然失色。
I completely agree. She is the last ruling pharaoh of Egypt. She is a prime actor in one of the greatest political dramas in all history. The last days of the Roman Republic, the rise of Rome to greatness, the death of Egypt as a sort of independent civilization. But also she's a remarkable woman because she's in a world dominated by men and she holds her own. She actually increases her dominions, doesn't she? Yes. And that's the thing. She doesn't just hold her own. I mean, there is a point at which it looks as though not only is she going to restore the empire that her forefathers ruled, but she's going to create something even greater. I mean, she is, I think, an absolutely extraordinary
我完全同意。她是埃及最后一位执政的法老。她是整个历史中最伟大的政治戏剧之一的核心演员。罗马共和国的最后日子，罗马走向伟大，埃及作为一种独立文明的消亡。但同时她也是一个非凡的女性，因为她身处一个由男性主导的世界却能立足。她实际上还扩大了自己的领土，不是吗？是的。这就是关键所在。她不仅仅是站稳了脚跟。我的意思是，有那么一个时刻，看起来不仅她将恢复她祖先统治过的帝国，而且她还要创建一个更伟大的帝国。我的意思是，我认为她是一个绝对非凡的
figure. And part of the fascination, of course, is that she's not only an extraordinary political figure, but she also has this aura of romance and glamour and myth about her, which is a huge part of her kind of public image today, but was generated by herself and by her enemies. And it's the kind of fusion of those two traditions that makes the whole story so fascinating. Well, that's what most of our listeners, if you don't know the story of Cleopatra terribly well, you will probably least vaguely know that she's involved with Julius Caesar. She's involved with Mark Antony. And she has this sort of tragic death.
人物。当然，部分魅力在于，她不仅是一个非凡的政治人物，而且她身上还散发着一种浪漫、迷人与神话的光环，这构成了她今天公众形象的很大一部分，但这也是由她自己和她的敌人所塑造的。正是这两种传统的融合，使得整个故事如此引人入胜。好吧，这就是我们大多数听众的感受，如果你对克娄巴特拉的故事不是非常了解，你可能隐约知道她与尤利乌斯·恺查（Julius Caesar）有染。她与马克·安东尼（Mark Antony）有染。而且她有着这样一种悲剧性的死亡。
And you'll know all that from innumerable plays, operas, musicals, video games. You know, she crops up everywhere from the Elizabeth Taylor film to kind of Assassin's Creed, the video game. Asterix, Carry On Films. Carry On Films, exactly. I mean, there's no other historical, I don't think there's any other female historical character who has been represented in so many different media and who also carries that sort of whiff of danger,
你会从无数的戏剧、歌剧、音乐剧、电子视频游戏中了解到所有这些。你知道的，她随处可见，从伊丽莎白·泰勒（Elizabeth Taylor）的电影到诸如《刺客信条》这样的电子游戏。还有《阿泰利克斯历险记》（Asterix）、《滑稽系列电影》（Carry On Films）。正是《滑稽系列电影》。我的意思是，没有其他历史——我认为没有其他女性历史人物曾在如此多的不同媒介中被展现过，并且像克娄巴特拉那样，
of sexual danger as Cleopatra. And as we'll discover, Tom, whether that is merited or not is kind of very interesting, because this is a kind of classic example of the way in which the myth, the legend itself is dazzling and remarkable and has generated great, great poetry. So there's the famous lines in Ant and Cleopatra by Shakespeare, where he portrays this story. And he has Cleopatra kind of stressing about what will happen after she and Antony have died. And she says, Antony shall be brought drunken forth, and I shall see some squeaking Cleopatra buoy my greatness in the posture of a whore. she's imagining that you know a boy will appear on
带有那种危险的气息，那种性感的危险。正如我们将要发觉的，汤姆，无论这种看法是否名副其实都非常有趣，因为这是一个经典的例子，神话和传说本身是如此耀眼和非凡，并孕育出了极佳的诗歌。因此，莎士比亚在《安东尼与克娄巴特拉》中写下了著名的台词，他在剧中描绘了这个故事。他让克娄巴特拉对她和安东尼死后会发生什么感到担忧。她说：“安东尼将被醉醺醺地带出来，而我将看到某个发出尖叫声的克娄巴特拉，在一个妓女的姿态中败坏我的伟大。”她想象着，你知道，一个男孩会出现在
the stage and pretend to be her um but in a way that's you know that's part of the kind of the extraordinary power of this is that cleopatra as a historical figure was playing a role as we will as we will discuss and it's precisely that kind of self-dramatization that has made her such a potent figure for Shakespeare, for Elizabeth Taylor, for everyone who's such an extraordinary kind of interplay and interaction. But Tom, I know you're incredibly keen to talk about the sort of, to do a lot of debunking and to talk about the sort of sources and stuff. So before we really kick off the narrative, which we intend to go through, you know, in real detail, as we have done in the past with Alexander and with the Falklands and things like that, it's worth saying, isn't it? I mean, you alluded to the fact that she self-mythologizes, but also there's a mythology created by her enemies. And the extraordinary thing about Cleopatra, of all these characters in history, she's one of the top four or five most famous
舞台上假装是她。但从某种程度上说，你知道，这也是这种非凡力量的一部分，即克娄巴特拉作为历史人物一直在扮演一个角色，正如我们将要讨论的那样，正是这种自我戏剧化，使她成为对莎士比亚、伊丽莎白·泰勒以及每个人来说都如此具有感染力的人物，这是一场多么非凡的相互交织和互动啊。但是汤姆，我知道你非常热衷于谈论那种——进行大量的去神秘化（debunking），并谈论各种资料来源之类的事情。所以在我们真正展开这个故事之前——我们打算像过去对待亚历山大、福克兰群岛之类的事情一样，非常详细地讲述它——这很值得一说，不是吗？我的意思是，你提到了她自我神话化，但也有她的敌人所创造的神话。而克娄巴特拉最非凡的地方在于，在历史上所有这些人物中，她是整个历史中最著名的前四五位
characters in all history. But almost every single thing we know about her comes from her enemies. That's right, isn't it? I mean, there's a handful of inscriptions. There are temple carvings. Coins. There are coins. But the written descriptions come from Roman sources that are actually describing her effect on the Romans. That's right, isn't it? There's nothing written down by Egyptians. There's no narrative by
人物之一。但关于她的几乎每一件小事都来自于她的敌人。对吧，不是吗？我的意思是，只有少数几处铭文。还有神庙雕刻。硬币。有硬币。但文字描述来自于实际描述她对罗马人产生影响的罗马资料。对吧，不是吗？没有任何由埃及人写下的东西。没有任何由
Egyptians. No, I think there is Josephus, who is a Jewish writer writing about 100 years after she lived, but then the Jews very much still do her as well. But having said that, I mean, it is absolutely possible to see the kind of the mythology that her as well. But having said that, I mean, it is absolutely possible to see the kind of mythology that she was spinning. So I think you do. And I think that part of the fascination of her character is precisely that actually those two traditions kind of meld and merge in a very kind of effective way, kind of gin and tonic effect.
埃及人撰写的叙述。不，我想约瑟夫斯（Josephus）是有的，他是一位犹太作家，写于她生活大约一百年之后，但犹太人当时也很大程度上在谈论她。话虽如此，我的意思是，完全有可能看出她自己也在编造的那种神话。所以我认为确实如此。而且我认为她的性格魅力的一部分恰恰在于，实际上这两种传统以一种非常有效的方式相互融合，产生了一种类似于金汤力（gin and tonic）的效果。
Right. That they're more fascinating for complementing each other if you see what i mean yeah no i do i absolutely see that i think we should um we should start by putting her in the context of the age that she's born and we we mentioned alexander the great so you begin your book with cleopatra as a young girl in the tomb of alexander right because the you've you've said that she's an Egyptian pharaoh, but the complicating factor is that she's not herself kind of an Egyptian. She's not bred of the mud of the Nile. She's not like the native pharaohs. She is the descendant of one of
对吧。如果你们明白我的意思的话，它们因为互补而更具迷人之处。是的，不，我完全明白。我认为我们应该——我们应该首先把她置于她所出生那个时代的背景中，我们提到了亚历山大大帝，所以你在书中以克娄巴特拉作为年轻女孩在亚历山大陵墓中的情景开篇，对吧？因为你——你已经说过她是一位埃及法老，但复杂之处在于她本人并不是某种埃及人。她不是尼罗河的泥土孕育的。她不像本土法老。她是亚历山大大帝的一位将军的后代。
Alexander the Great's generals. Yeah, that's right. So there's always an element of any biography of Cleopatra, there's always an element of a fiction or speculation because we know so little about her early life. And when I was kicking off my own kids book, I thought, you know, there's the challenge of doing this massive kind of info dumps. And one way of doing of dramatizing it is imagining something that she would undoubtedly have done. We know that the Ptolemies did this. They had festivals around Alexander's tomb because Alexander's tomb was in Alexandria. So it's not a flight of fantasy to imagine her there. So why does that matter? Because in the fourth century, as we discussed it, the fourth century BC, as we discussed in our Alexander podcasts, Alexander had led these armies out of Macedonia and conquered so much of what
是的，没错。因此，关于克娄巴特拉的任何传记中总是带有一点虚构或猜测的成分，因为我们对她的早年生活知之甚少。当我开始写自己的儿童读物时，我想，你知道，这里面临着需要塞入大量背景信息的挑战。而将其戏剧化的一种方法就是想象一些她无疑做过的事情。我们知道托勒密家族就是这么做的。他们在亚历山大的陵墓周围举办节日，因为亚历山大的陵墓就在亚历山大港。所以想象她在那里并非凭空幻想。那么这为什么重要呢？因为在公元前四世纪，正如我们在关于亚历山大的播客中所讨论的那样，亚历山大带领这些军队离开马其顿，征服了过去被称为近东的大部分地区，包括埃及。在他死后，帝国被瓜分给了他的各路将领。
used to be called the Near East, including Egypt. And at his death, the empire had been divided up among his kind of captains. And the shrewdest and basically the cleverest of them, Ptolemy, his old friend who'd been educated by the feet of Aristotle alongside Alexander, he goes off to Egypt. He says he wants Egypt because it's the richest, but it's the easiest to defend because it's kind of at the end of the line, if you know what I mean. So it's easy to, you know, it's wealthy. You've got the wealth of the Nile, but you can,
其中最精明也最聪明的托勒密，他曾与亚历山大一起在亚里士多德脚下受教育的老朋友，他去了埃及。他说他想要埃及，因为它是最富裕的，但也是最容易防守的，因为它处于路线的尽头，如果你懂我的意思的话。所以它很容易——你知道的，它很富裕。你拥有尼罗河的财富，但是只要你能守住三角洲的防线，
as long as you can hold the line at the Delta, you can stop anybody breaking in. And Ptolemy goes, he rules as Pharaoh. So as Alexander had done, he sort of assimilates to egyptian traditions doesn't he takes a key yes a key legitimizing item which is the coffin of alexander the great doesn't he i mean he literally transports it from babylon where alexander has died and takes it all the way to egypt that's which is you know the imprimatur of his own it's it's it's the greek imprimatur of
你就能阻止任何人闯入。托勒密去了，他作为法老进行统治。因此，正如亚历山大曾经做过的那样，他某种程度上同化了埃及的传统，不是吗？他拿走了一个关键的——是的，一个关键的合法化物品，那就是亚历山大大帝的棺材，不是吗？我的意思是，他字面意义上把它从亚历山大去世的巴比伦运送过来，一路运到埃及，这可以说是他自己的——这是他未来埃及法老地位的希腊式授权。
what will become his egypt Egyptian pharaonic status. So what happens, what's so interesting, right at the beginning is you have this melding of Egyptian and Macedonian Greek traditions. So they wear the double crown of Upper and Lower Egypt. They are depicted, these sort of Macedonian adventurers are depicted as Egyptian pharaohs, but they have a brand new capital built on the shores of the Mediterranean and the site supposedly chosen by Alexander himself, Alexandria. And at the very heart of Alexandria, as you say, is the tomb of Alexander. And the interesting thing is they depict themselves as Egyptians. They are very respectful to the priests, but it's really important to them that they are still Macedonian Greeks. And his son, also Ptolemy, takes over.
所以发生了什么，最有趣的是，就在刚开始的时候，你拥有了埃及传统与马其顿希腊传统的融合。所以他们佩戴上埃及和下埃及的双重王冠。他们被描绘成——这些马其顿冒险家被描绘成埃及法老，但他们在死海（应为地中海）海岸建立了一个全新的首都，这个地点据说是亚历山大亲自选定的，也就是亚历山大港。而在亚历山大港的中心，正如你所说，就是亚历山大的陵墓。有趣的是，他们把自己描绘成埃及人。他们对祭司非常尊敬，但对他们来说极其重要的是，他们仍然是马其顿希腊人。他的儿子，同样叫托勒密的人接管了政权。
And he's called Ptolemy Philadelphus, which means the sibling lover. And he's called that because he marries his own sister, Arsinoe. And that then starts the trend, the thing that Ptolemy is most famous for. So it's like this sort of clan of warriors have established themselves, but they're sticking to their own, even though they're very careful at turning up at Egyptian temple ceremonies and all that sort of stuff. But they're still very, very Greek.
他被称为托勒密·费拉德尔福斯（Ptolemy Philadelphus），意思是“爱兄妹的人”。他被称为这个名字是因为他娶了自己的亲妹妹阿尔西诺伊（Arsinoe）。这就开启了一种趋势，也是托勒密最为人所知的特点。所以这就像是一群武士建立了他们自己的人马，但他们坚持自己的核心，尽管他们非常小心地出现在埃及神庙的仪式以及所有诸如此类的活动中。但他们仍然是非常非常希腊化的。
But they could point out that Hera and Zeus, so the queen and the king of the Greek gods, married one another. And they're very good at finding Greek parallels for Egyptian elements. And so they even construct a god, Serapis, who is a combination of Heracles and Osiris and all these various Greek and Egyptian gods. And they invent him and he becomes essentially the presiding deity of Alexandria. But I think it is important to emphasize that the predominant tone of the Greek inhabitants of Alexandria, and I think of the Ptolemies themselves, by and large, right the way up into Cleopatra. And this is why Cleopatra is such a key figure. Most of the Ptolemies are pretty contemptuous
但他们可以指出，赫拉（Hera）和宙斯（Zeus）——也就是希腊神话中的王后和国王——互相结婚了。他们非常善于为埃及元素寻找希腊的对应物。因此，他们甚至创造了一个神，塞拉匹斯（Serapis），他是赫拉克勒斯（Heracles）和奥西里斯（Osiris）以及各种希腊和埃及神祇的结合体。他们发明了这个神，它基本上成为了亚历山大港的主导神明。但我认为必须强调的是，亚历山大的希腊居民的主导基调，我认为包括托勒密家族本身，大体上一直延续到克娄巴特拉。这也是为什么克娄巴特拉是一个如此关键的人物。大多数托勒密家族成员相当轻蔑
of Egypt and Egyptian culture, and they regard the wealth of Egypt as something to be leeched. So the Egyptians themselves, I think, view Alexandria as a foreign city, like an enormous kind of great tick that has attached itself to the body of Egypt and is just leeching all the blood out of it. Well, Tom, I mentioned Assassin's Creed as one of the depictions of Cleopatra. Now, I know you're not a video games person, but anybody who has played video games or has played that particular video game, Assassin's Creed Origins, will know that it creates this colossal
埃及和埃及文化，他们将埃及的财富视为可以榨取的东西。因此，我认为埃及人本身将亚历山大港视为一个外国城市，就像一只巨大的、可怕的壁虱附着在埃及的躯体上，不断吸干它的血液。好吧，汤姆，我提到了《刺客信条》作为对克娄巴特拉的描绘之一。现在，我知道你不是一个玩电子游戏的人，但任何玩过电子游戏或玩过那款特定游戏《刺客信条：起源》的人都会知道，它创造了一个庞大
and incredibly detailed portrait of Ptolemaic Egypt. And it's all very Egyptian pyramids and kind of huts and the Nile and all that sort of stuff. And in the game, which has been done with sort of intense cooperation with kind of historians and archaeologists, you get to Alexandria and it's marble colonnades and it's people and the other characters are talking in Greek rather than in Egyptian. And it's sort of scholars strolling in gardens.
且极其详尽的托勒密埃及画像。到处都是埃及金字塔、各种小屋、尼罗河以及所有这些东西。在这款游戏中——它是在与历史学家和考古学家进行深入合作下完成的——当你到达亚历山大港时，那里有大理石柱廊，有各种各样的人，其他角色说的也是希腊语而不是埃及语。还有学者们在花园里漫步。
And it feels very, very Greek, as indeed Alexandria must. I mean, it was cosmopolitan, but it saw itself, didn't it, as part of the Greek world? Well, I mean, it's literally cosmopolis. It's the city of the universe. And the ambition of Alexandria is to contain within its streets everything. So it's great harbors to contain ships that have come from across the world, not just from the Mediterranean, but from India and Africa. And of course, its famous library, again, the ambition is to contain all the learning that there is. But this ambition is a Greek ambition. And the city is a Greek city. And the rulers are Greek. And the relationship with Egypt
感觉非常非常希腊化，正如亚历山大港必然的那样。我的意思是，它是国际化的，但它把自己视为——不是吗？——希腊世界的一部分。好吧，我的意思是，它字面意义上就是世界大同（cosmopolis）。它是宇宙之城。亚历山大港的雄心是在其街道中容纳一切。所以它有伟大的港口来容纳来自世界各地的船只，不仅来自地中海，还来自印度和非洲。当然，还有它著名的图书馆，同样，其雄心是容纳现存所有的学问。但这种雄心是一种希腊式的雄心。这座城市是一座希腊城市。统治者是希腊人。因此，与埃及的关系
is always therefore incredibly paradoxical. I mean, it's a proper kind of, it is a colonial relationship right the way up to the time of Cleopatra. And one of the things that make Cleopatra so distinctive is that she moves beyond that. Tom into a world in which that empire the Ptolemaic empire is a shadow of it so so what what's happened would you say to what's gone wrong so we talked about Alexander and as one bookend of a distinctive period that historians call the Hellenistic era and Cleopatra is the other and the Hellenistic period basically describes the successor empires, the successor states of Alexander. And to begin with, they're incredibly potent. And Ptolemaic Egypt is one of basically three successor states. However, what happens over the course of the second and first centuries BC is that a new superpower is rising in the West. And there has never been a superpower like it in
永远是极其矛盾的。我的意思是，这是一种彻头彻尾的——直到克娄巴特拉时代，这都是一种殖民关系。而使克娄巴特拉如此与众不同的原因之一，就是她超越了这一点。汤姆，进入了一个这样的世界：那个帝国——托勒密帝国只是昔日的一个影子。那么——发生了什么，你会怎么说——哪里出了问题？所以我们谈到了亚历山大，作为历史学家称之为希腊化时代的一个独特时期的两个书挡之一，而克娄巴特拉则是另一个。希腊化时期基本上描述的是亚历山大的继承者帝国、继承者国家。起初，它们极其强大。而托勒密埃及基本上是三个继承国之一。然而，在公元前二世纪和一世纪的过程中，发生的事情是一个新的超级大国正在西方崛起。在
the Mediterranean. And by the time that Cleopatra is born, essentially, the whole of the Mediterranean has come under the influence, the authority of this emergent superpower. And that superpower, of course, is Rome, which is a republic. And the republic is founded on a contempt for kings, which means that the very structure of government in Alexandria, haven't they? So they had expanded beyond their borders. They'd held kind of Cyprus and Cyrene, which is now Libya and parts of Syria. But that's all being whittled away by the Romans, isn't it? And the Alexandrian crowd who are always... So Alexandria is both a city of philosophy and great learning, but it's also got this terrible tradition of rioting.
地中海从未有过这样的超级大国。到克娄巴特拉出生时，基本上整个地中海都已经落入了这一新兴超级大国的影响力和权威之下。而这个超级大国，当然就是罗马，它是一个共和国。这个共和国建立在对国王的蔑视之上，这意味着亚历山大港的整个政府结构——它们不是已经扩张到了边界之外吗？它们曾占有塞浦路斯和昔兰尼（Cyrene，现今的利比亚）以及叙利亚的部分地区。但这一切都被罗马人一点点蚕食了，不是吗？还有亚历山大港的民众，他们总是——所以亚历山大港既是一座充满哲学和伟大学问的城市，但它也有着可怕的暴动传统。
Well, it's officially a democracy. I mean, that's another kind of fascinating aspect of it, is that it's a monarchy, but it's also a democracy i mean that's that's another kind of fascinating aspect of it is that it's a monarchy but it's also a democracy and so the people of alexandria they're always throwing out yeah ptolemies and replacing them with their brothers and uh there's a tradition that the women of alexandria in riots will go and grab people's testicles men's oh that's nice yeah that's that's a distinctive feature of Alexander and Ryan. I didn't put that in the George's book. No, I hope not. So, yeah, Cleopatra. So let's talk a tiny bit about Cleopatra's parents. So we know who her father was.
好吧，它官方是一个民主政体。我的意思是，这也是另一个引人入胜的方面，它是君主制，但它同时也是一个民主政体——我的意思是，这也是另一个引人入胜的方面，它是君主制，但它同时也是一个民主政体。所以亚历山大港的人民，他们总是把托勒密赶下台，换上他们的兄弟，而且——有一个传统，亚历山大港的女性在暴动时会去抓人们的睾丸，男人们的——哦，那挺好，是的，那是亚历山大暴动的一个独特特征。我没有把这个写进乔治的书里。不，希望没有。所以，是的，克娄巴特拉。让我们稍微谈谈克娄巴特拉的父母。所以我们知道她的父亲是谁。
He is Ptolemy XII, who's nicknamed Auletes, the flute player. The clarinet player. And some people always say that's very – well, there are two different schools of thought on this, as far as I can tell. One is that this is because he's dissipated and he spends all his time at parties which seems like a very roman way of orientalizing way of describing autonomy and the other is that he's called this because he enjoyed the religion of dionysus um and that you know playing the flute or the clarinet and sort of dancing and all that sort of stuff was part of the religious sort of tradition. What's your take on Cleopatra's father? Well, he has a very bad hand. And he has a bad hand because over the course of his reign,
他是托勒密十二世（Ptolemy XII），绰号“吹笛者”（Auletes，即吹单簧管的人）。有些人总是说这非常——好吧，据我所知，对此有两种不同的看法。一种看法是，这是因为他放荡不羁，把所有时间都花在聚会上——这听起来像是罗马人东方化地描述一个托勒密的方式；另一种看法是，他被称为这个是因为他喜爱狄奥尼索斯（Dionysus）的宗教，呃，你知道，吹笛子或单簧管，跳舞以及所有诸如此类的事情是宗教传统的一部分。你对克娄巴特拉的父亲有什么看法？好吧，他拿到了一手很烂的牌。他拿到烂牌是因为在他的统治期间，
the other great rival, traditional rival of Egypt, Ptolemaic Egypt, Syria, the Seleucid Empire, it gets extinguished by Pompey the Great, who is Rome's greatest general in the 60s and 50s BC. And he extinguishes Seleucid independence, he captures Jerusalem, he goes back to Rome, kind of trailing kings and wealth and glory. But he doesn't take over Egypt. Egypt is left, but it's absolutely under-sufferance. And one of the reasons why Egypt is not taken over is that it's too rich. So Pompey's rivals will not permit him to annex Egypt, but nor will anyone else be allowed to do it because it's simply too rich. And so that's a very humiliating position for Ptolemy Auletes to be in, because
托勒密埃及的另一个伟大对手、传统对手——叙利亚、塞琉古帝国（Seleucid Empire）——在公元前 60 年代和 50 年代被罗马最伟大的将军庞培大帝（Pompey the Great）消灭了。他消灭了塞琉古的独立，占领了耶路撒冷，然后回到罗马，身后拖着一串国王、财富和荣耀。但他没有接管埃及。埃及被留下了，但它完全是在容忍之下苟延残喘。而埃及没有被吞并的原因之一是它太富有了。所以庞培的对手不允许他吞并埃及，但其他人也不允许这样做，因为它实在太富有了。因此，对于托勒密·奥勒特斯来说，这是一个非常屈辱的处境，因为
basically he's on the throne precisely because he is seen as so weak. And the nickname, I think, I mean, I think it has a kind of double resonance. It symbolizes for the Romans, the fact that Ptolemaic Egypt is contemptible, decadent. It's all about, you know, they're not interested in manly things like conquering Gaul or stuff like that. They're just interested in parties. But also it's sinister because there are religious traditions. These are, you know, Egypt is a land where the gods have animal heads and all kinds of ancient, dark, sinister practices. None of it that is really conducive with the stern ancestral republican traditions of Rome. I mean, there's a slight, you know, it's anachronistic, but the way in which, say,
基本上他能坐上王位，恰恰是因为他被视为如此软弱。而这个绰号，我认为——我的意思是，我认为它具有双重共鸣。对罗马人来说，它象征着托勒密埃及是令人鄙视的、腐朽的。这一切都意味着，你知道，他们对征服高卢之类具有男子气概的事情不感兴趣，他们只对聚会感兴趣。但这也是险恶的，因为这里存在着宗教传统。这些是——你知道，埃及是一个神灵拥有动物头颅以及各种古老、黑暗、险恶习俗的土地。这些没有一样真正符合罗马严厉的祖传共和传统。我的意思是，这有点——虽然有点不合时宜，但其性质就像，比如说，
you know, republican Americans would look at the monarchies of Europe in the 19th century, something of that quality, I think, is there. That makes complete sense. But then there's the issue of her mother. So his wife, Ptolemy's wife, was called Cleopatra Trifina, and she was often thought to have been, we're not exactly sure, but she's probably some kind of relative, some part of the clan, but not his sister. But there is some doubt, or doubt is is sometimes expressed about cleopatra's own ethnicity because for example when gal gado the israeli actress said that she wanted to remake
19世纪的共和制美国人看待欧洲君主国的那种方式，我认为其中存在着某种类似的特质。这完全讲得通。但接下来是关于她母亲的问题。所以他的妻子，托勒密的妻子名叫克娄巴特拉·特里菲娜（Cleopatra Tryphaena），人们常认为她——我们不太确定，但她可能是某种亲戚、家族的一部分，但不是他的姐姐。不过，人们对克娄巴特拉本人的种族有时也存在一些疑问或表达怀疑。例如，当以色列女演员盖尔·加朵（Gal Gadot）表示她想翻拍
elizabeth taylor's cleopatra and she wanted to play cleopatra there was torrent outpouring of out of outrage um people saying cleopatra was black how can you how can you do this she was egyptian but i mean i think most scholars would say that's absolute tosh, would they, Tom? She's Macedonian. She's undoubtedly Macedonian. Yeah. I mean, if she wasn't, it would have been mentioned.
伊丽莎白·泰勒的《克娄巴特拉》并想扮演克娄巴特拉时，引发了一股愤怒的狂潮，人们纷纷说克娄巴特拉是黑人，你怎么能这么做，她是埃及人。但我的意思是，我想大多数学者都会说那是绝对的胡说八道吧，汤姆？她是马其顿人。她无疑是马其顿人。是的。我的意思是，如果她不是，肯定会被提及的。
Well, the key thing, I think, and lots of scholars say this, is although it's not explicitly stated in the sources that her mother was Ptolemy's wife, so it's possible that she could have some other mother, Egyptian mother. The Romans would almost certainly have made use of it, wouldn't they? They'd have said she was-
好吧，我认为关键在于——许多学者也这么说，尽管资料中没有明确说明她的母亲是托勒密的妻子，所以她有可能拥有其他母亲，比如埃及母亲。但罗马人几乎肯定会利用这一点，不是吗？他们会说她是——
Well, so also would her siblings. Because the salient thing about the Ptolemies is that they're a horrific family. I mean, they are terrifying. And the female of the species tends to be deadlier than the male so the girls are just as likely to stab in the back and kill if not more so than the the than the boys can i tell you my favorite um ptolemy ptolemy family family relationship it's um ptolemy
好吧，她的兄弟姐妹们也会这么做。因为托勒密家族最显著的特点是这是一个可怕的家族。我的意思是，他们太吓人了。而且这个物种的女性往往比男性更致命，所以女孩们捅刀子和杀人的可能性和男孩们一样高，甚至更高。我可以告诉你我最喜欢的——呃，托勒密家族的家庭关系吗？那是托勒密
the eighth whose name was physcon which i think Fatty yeah Fatty Abyss Abyss so so he married his sister Cleopatra II who had previously been married to their brother and had had a child by him but then he tired of his own sister so he married her daughter who was also his niece so now was at once his niece his daughter-in-law and his second wife all at once and his and his wife wait for it tom his wife got was cross and said how dare you marry my daughter you know you're married to me my brother and so he was infuriated by his wife nagging him said you know what he did he um he killed their 14 year old son chopped him up and gave him to his wife as a birthday present yeah well so so they people periodically have tried to make films about or tv series about
八世，他的绰号叫菲斯孔（Physcon），也就是胖子——肥胖的深渊。所以——所以他娶了他的姐姐克娄巴特拉二世，她以前曾嫁给他们的兄弟，并为那个兄弟生过一个孩子，但他后来厌倦了自己的姐姐，于是他娶了自己的女儿——她同时也是他的侄女。所以她同时成为了他的侄女、儿媳和第二任妻子。而且他的妻子——等等，汤姆，他的妻子很生气，说：“你怎么敢娶我女儿？你知道你嫁给了我，我的兄弟。”所以他被妻子的唠叨激怒了，你知道他做了什么吗？他——他杀了他们 14 岁的儿子，把他切成碎块，作为生日礼物送给了他的妻子。好吧，所以人们曾周期性地试图拍摄关于托勒密家族的电影或电视剧，
the Ptolemies and it's so confusing that it never quite works but that kind of mafia ambience is absolutely key to one that these are murderous terrifying, but they're also seen by the light of the Romans contemptible. So the other famous story that's told about that Ptolemy is that Scipio Aemilianus, who is the great war hero who has captured Carthage and is the absolute epitome of Roman militarism, turns up in Alexandria and he walks at a brisk pace through the streets. And poor old Ptolemy is enormously fat and dressed in silk. And he kind of every wobble and undulation as he totters and pants after Scipio is on display to the people of Alexandria. And it's a kind of deliberate attempt by the Romans to kind of humiliate them. I think that we should take a
但由于关系太混乱，从来没有真正成功过。不过那种黑手党般的氛围绝对是关键之一：这些人是残暴恐怖的，但在罗马人的轻蔑眼光中，他们也是令人鄙视的。因此，关于那个托勒密的另一个著名故事是，曾攻克迦太基、作为罗马军国主义绝对化身的伟大战争英雄小西庇阿（Scipio Aemilianus）出现在亚历山大港，他迈着轻快的步伐走过街道。而可怜的托勒密胖得不成样子，身穿丝绸。当他在小西庇阿身后蹒跚气喘时，身上的每一层赘肉和波纹都暴露在亚历山大港人民的面前。这是罗马人蓄意羞辱他们的一种尝试。我认为我们应该在此时
break at this point. And that when we come back, we should look more closely at the geopolitics of the world that Cleopatra is born into, and the kind of the context that explains why her career is such a kind of triumph against the odds. Very good. We'll see you in a minute. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews,
休息一下。当我们回来时，应该更仔细地审视克娄巴特拉出生那个世界的地缘政治，以及解释为什么她的职业生涯是一场战胜逆境的伟大胜利的背景。非常好。我们一会儿见。我是玛丽娜·海德（Marina Hyde）。我是理查德·奥斯曼（Richard Osman）。我们共同主持《娱乐其余部分》（The Rest Is Entertainment）。这是你每周获取娱乐新闻、评论、
splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com.
一抹演艺界八卦的地方。在我们的问答环节中，我们拉开娱乐业的帷幕，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚启动了我们的会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告的收听体验、加更节目以及抢先购买现场门票的权限，请前往 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。
Tom, it has been a little while, sadly, since we talked about our much-loved and learned sponsors at UnHerd, the online magazine. Would that be U-N-H-E-R-D? That's precisely the spelling. Now, as you all know, Tom, or I hope you haven't forgotten, it's an online magazine that kicks back against herd mentality. Now, we're in the middle of talking about Cleopatra.
汤姆，不幸的是，自从我们讨论过我们在在线杂志《UnHerd》上备受喜爱和尊重的赞助商以来，已经有一段时间了。那会是 U-N-H-E-R-D 吗？正是这个拼写。现在，正如你们所有人所知道的——汤姆，或者我希望你没有忘记——这是一本反对羊群心理（herd mentality）的在线杂志。现在，我们正处于谈论克娄巴特拉的过程中。
UnHerd's Kat Rosenfield has been looking into the cult, the fading cult, perhaps, of the girl boss, something I know you care a lot about, Tom, and it's perhaps best exemplified by Elizabeth Holmes, founder of the fraudulent multi-billion dollar health startup Theranos. This is a subject I know a lot about. Theranos sounds very sinister. Is sinister. Well, Theranos is basically a Bond villains organization, isn't it? Theranos. You'd immediately think that's evil. I do think it's evil. Well, i'm just i don't want to be sued
UnHerd 的凯特·罗森菲尔德（Kat Rosenfield）一直在研究“大女主”（girl boss）的邪教，或者说正在消逝的邪教。我知道你非常关心这一点，汤姆，这或许最好由 Theranos 的创始人伊丽莎白·霍姆斯（Elizabeth Holmes）来体现，这是一家涉嫌欺诈的数十亿美元健康初创公司。这是一个我非常了解的话题。Theranos 听起来非常险恶。确实很险恶。好吧，Theranos 基本上是一个邦德反派组织，对吧？Theranos。你一听就会觉得那是邪恶的。我确实认为那是邪恶的。好吧，我只是——我不想被
by theranos i'm sure they're lovely uh but they do sound evil well should i tell you what cat writes yes would you enjoy that yeah cat writes the myth of theranos might have shattered but the legend of its founder lingers on and as long as society remains enthralled to the narrative of the disruptor the glass ceiling breaker the patriarchy smasher. She won't be the only one. If Elizabeth Holmes hadn't existed, we would have had to invent her. And in some ways, we did. Do you have thoughts on that, Tom? Well, in light of what we're saying about Cleopatra, that's not without a certain relevance, is it?
Theranos 起诉，我确信他们人很好——但听起来确实很邪恶。好吧，要我告诉你凯特写了什么吗？是的，你想听吗？太好了。凯特写道：“Theranos 的神话可能已经破灭，但其创始人的传奇依然存在。只要社会仍然迷恋颠覆者、玻璃天花板打破者、父权制粉碎者的叙事，她就不会是唯一的一个。如果伊丽莎白·霍姆斯不存在，我们也得发明她。从某种意义上说，我们确实这样做了。”汤姆，你对此有什么看法吗？嗯，鉴于我们一直在谈论克娄巴特拉，这并非毫无关联，不是吗？
It's incredibly relevant. Yeah. yeah that's that's not without a certain relevance is it it's incredibly relevant yeah and the sense in which Cleopatra was a a genuine you know she genuinely broke through all kinds of glass ceilings she did but is also the invention of uh those who were terrified of her the important thing is to say that if you want to kick back against herd mentality which I do I very much do you can join unheard today and get three months free, Dominic. Three months. That's not even a bargain. It's a freebie. It absolutely is. They're giving it away. So just go to unheard.com, that's U-N-H-E-R-D, forward slash rest, R-E-S-T, to claim this offer now. Right back to Cleopatra.
这极其相关。是的。是的，这并非毫无关联，不是吗？这极其相关。是的。而且，从某种意义上说，克娄巴特拉是一位真正的——她真正打破了各种玻璃天花板，她确实做到了；但她同时也是那些对她感到恐惧的人所创造的产物。重要的一点是，如果你想反击羊群心理——而我确实很想，你可以今天就加入 UnHerd 并获得三个月的免费期，多米尼克。三个月。这甚至不是一笔划算的交易。这是一个免费赠品。这绝对是。他们在免费大放送。所以只要访问 unheard.com——也就是 U-N-H-E-R-D，斜杠 rest（R-E-S-T）——现在就可以领取这个优惠。让我们马上回到克娄巴特拉。
Welcome back to The Rest is History. Tom, you were very excitedly going to talk about geopolitical context for the world in which, so Cleopatra, we've been talking for more than 20 minutes and she's only just been born. Well, because I think the context is really fascinating, which is that essentially so we've talked about say british imperial power and we've talked about countries like argentina being as you know or egypt say actually yeah being part uh of an unofficial empire in which britain's military financial naval power was such that they didn't have to come you know they didn't have to be administered by a British plenipotentiary, but they essentially couldn't do anything that the British didn't want them to do. And that's a very analogous situation to Egypt's relationship to Rome in the first century.
欢迎回到《历史其余部分》。汤姆，你之前非常兴奋地准备谈论克娄巴特拉出生世界的地缘政治背景——我们已经谈了二十多分钟，而她才刚刚出生。嗯，因为我认为这个背景真的非常迷人，也就是说，我们谈到了英国的帝国权力，我们谈到了像阿根廷这样的国家——你知道的，或者埃及——实际上是成为一个非正式帝国的一部分，在这个帝国中，英国的军事、财政和海军力量如此强大，以至于他们不必亲自前来（你知道，他们不必由英国全权代表来管理），但他们基本上不能做任何英国人不想让他们做的事情。这与公元一世纪埃及与罗马的关系非常相似。
The problem that the Hellenistic, the Greek world around the Near East had faced throughout the first century is that the Romans were unwilling to tolerate anyone who might kind of conceivably rival them. So every time some king stood up and tried to impose a degree of order or to display a degree of autonomy, the legions would come, topple him, hamstrung his elephants, drag his treasure off to be spent in rome all that kind of stuff um but the romans didn't want the hassle of actually administering this stuff they didn't want to send in you know it would cost too much in terms of of money and men to bother with all that so essentially the near east becomes a breeding ground for anarchy which is part of why
整个一世纪期间，近东周边的希腊化、希腊世界所面临的问题是，罗马人不愿容忍任何可能在想象中与他们匹敌的人。所以每当某个国王站出来试图施加某种秩序或展示某种自治时，军团就会到来，推翻他，打断他大象的脚筋，把他的财富拖到罗马去花掉，诸如此类的事情。但罗马人又不想承担实际管理这些地方的麻烦，他们不想派人进去——因为在金钱和人力方面，费心去搞这些代价太高了。所以本质上，近东成了无政府状态的温床，这也是这些希腊化王国最终走向崩溃的部分原因。
these hellenistic kingdoms end up just collapsing. And Egypt really is, as the last kingdom left standing, it's in a really, really difficult position because it is massively under Rome's military and financial thumb, but it doesn't even have the benefit of knowing where it stands with Rome because it's constantly subject to the ambitions of all these kind of various rival warlords and bankers. Well, this is the thing. So Auletes, who we talked about, Cleopatra's father, I mean, he's best known in Rome because basically his way of dealing with all this is to try and play off all the different Roman power brokers by bribing them, isn't it? So you've got Pompey the Great, who's who models himself and alexander the great so he's all these people it's so interesting isn't it um we we were talking about this as a kind of
埃及确实作为最后一个屹立不倒的王国，处于一个非常非常困难的境地，因为它在军事和财政上被罗马死死拿捏，但它甚至连自己在罗马面前处于什么地位都不知道，因为它不断受到各种相互争夺的军阀和银行家的野心的摆布。好了，就是这个。所以我们谈到的奥勒特斯，克娄巴特拉的父亲，我的意思是，他在罗马最出名是因为他应对这一切的方法基本上是试图通过贿赂来挑拨所有不同的罗马权力掮客，对吧？所以你有庞培大帝，他把自己塑造为——亚历山大大帝，所以所有这些人，这真是太有趣了，不是吗？我们之前讨论过这作为我们亚历山大播客的一种
sequel to our alexander podcast and and it makes sense to see it that way because all the characters think they're in a sequel to the alexander podcast yeah don't they are i mean he does his hair like alexander he claims he's got alex Alexander's cloak. He's always standing in profile. Yes, exactly. He can kind of show off his quiff. And as we'll see, you know, one of Mark Antony's, one of the parts of his great downfall is he launches this invasion, which is an attempt to kind of reproduce the glory of Alexander
续集，这样看是合情合理的，因为所有的角色都觉得自己是在亚历山大播客的续集里，不是吗？他们确实是。我的意思是，他把头发弄得像亚历山大一样，他声称自己拥有亚历山大的斗篷。他总是以侧面站立。是的， exatamente。他可以炫耀他的刘海。正如我们将看到的，你知道，马克·安东尼的重大败笔之一就是他发起了这场入侵，企图通过攻击波斯来
in attacking the Persians. So Auletes, he sends Pompey a golden crown. He sends Julius Caesar 6,000 silver talents. So he's basically throwing money around. And the problem is that that money, I mean, most of it is raised from the long-suffering Egyptian peasantry. Egypt is the breadbasket of the Mediterranean,
重现亚历山大的荣耀。所以奥勒特斯，他送给庞培一顶金冠。他送给尤利乌斯·恺撒 6,000 白银塔兰特。所以他基本上在到处挥霍金钱。问题在于，这些钱——其中大部分是从饱受苦难的埃及农民身上搜刮来的。埃及是地中海的粮仓，
so therefore there's enormous amounts of money there, but they just keep screwing more and more money out of the long-suffering peasantry. But also he borrows a substantial chunk. So this banker called Rabirius, and this is a problem for Ptolemy in exactly the way that, say, a third world country that gets into debt
因此那里有巨额财富，但他们只是不断地从备受折磨的农民身上榨取更多的金钱。而且他也借了一大笔巨款。所以有个叫拉比里乌斯（Rabirius）的银行家，这对于托勒密来说是个大问题，就像一个第三世界国家陷入对国际货币基金组织（IMF）等的债务一样。这是一个巨大的问题。但当然，这也随之成为了罗马人的问题，因为他们需要把钱拿回来。
to the IMF or something. It's a huge problem. But of course, it then also becomes a problem for the Romans because they need their money back. Well, they need their money, but also it infuriates the Alexandrian crowd because they're very proud, aren't they? They hate the Romans. They're inflamed by the fact that their own country has got,
好吧，他们需要他们的钱，但这同时也激怒了亚历山大港的民众，因为他们非常自傲，不是吗？他们讨厌罗马人。他们被这样事实激怒了：他们自己的国家拥有，正如他们所说，沉重的赋税去贿赂罗马的权力掮客。而奥勒特斯陷入了一种不可能维持的平衡状态。他不能疏远罗马人，否则他们会入侵、把他踢出去并换上其他人。但同样地，他也不能对他们谄媚过头，否则他自己的人民会发起反抗。而在公元前 58 年左右——当时克娄巴特拉大概 10 岁时——事情就是这样发生的。托勒密字面意义上去了意大利。
as they say, crippling taxes to bribe Roman power brokers. And Auletus has got this impossible balancing act. He can't alienate the Romans because otherwise they'll invade, kick him out and replace him with somebody else. But equally, he can't suck up to them too much because his own people will rise up against him. And that's what happens in, I think, 58 BC when Cleopatra is probably about 10. And Ptolemy has literally gone to Italy. Yeah. There are huge riots, aren't there?
发生了巨大的暴乱，不是吗？他基本上被推翻了。他最后——他不是去见马库斯·加图（Marcus Cato）了吗，经历了一次可怕的会面，汤姆，当时加图正在上厕所。是的。加图被设定为正直和端正行为的楷模。作为罗马共和国的传统代表，他对肥胖和软弱的埃及国王感到无比轻蔑，是的，他坚持在厕所里与他处理所有的业务。
And he basically ends up toppled. He ends up, doesn't he go to, has this terrible meeting with Marcus Cato, Tom, when Cato is on the toilet. Yeah. So Cato has been set. Cato is the model of integrity and upright behavior. And as a traditional representative of the Roman Republic, is utterly contemptuous of kind of fat and feed Egyptian kings. And yes, insists on conducting all his business with him on the toilet.
然后他基本上最终被推翻了。他最终，他不是去，跟马库斯·加图有了一次糟糕的会面吗，汤姆，当时加图正在上厕所。是的。所以加图被设定为正直和正派行为的模范。作为罗马共和国的传统代表，他对那种脑满肠肥的埃及国王充满了蔑视，并且坚持在厕所里和对方谈所有生意。
So Auletus has been kicked out by his own own people and they replace him with cleopatra and by his own daughter yeah both cleopatra's older sister berenike um so they're all they all have the same what's slightly annoying is that all the people in the ptolemaic dynasty they only have one of about five names don't they ptolemy osinui berenikeopatra. It must be some other male name, but I don't know. They're just all called Ptolemy. So she takes over, and she rules for, what, three years? While her father is in Italy trying to raise the money and the men. So he's got all this cash that he's kind of extorted from the peasantry, borrowed from Robirius, the banker,
奥勒提斯被他自己的人民赶下台，他们用克娄巴特拉取而代之，而且是他的亲生女儿，没错，就是克娄巴特拉年龄较大的姐姐贝勒尼基。嗯，所以他们名字都一样，有点烦人的是，托勒密王朝的所有人大约只有五个名字，对吧？托勒密、奥西尼、贝勒尼基、克娄巴特拉。肯定还有另一个男人的名字，但我不知道。他们都叫托勒密。所以她掌权了，统治了大约三年？当时她父亲在意大利试图筹集资金和招募士兵。所以他手里有从农民那里勒索来、又向银行家拉比乌斯借来的所有这些现金，
and he's raising the money to come back and take Egypt back. Berenike, meanwhile, has married a guy called Seleucus. He's a brilliant man. Do you know what? If you've got his nickname, Tan. Saltfish hawker. Yeah, the saltfish monger, the translation I have, because he's stank of fish.
他正在筹集资金回来夺回埃及。与此同时，贝勒尼基嫁给了一个叫塞琉ucus的家伙。他是个聪明人。你知道吗？如果你知道他的外号的话，丹。咸鱼小贩。对，我看到的翻译是咸鱼商贩，因为他身上有一股鱼腥味。
Well, the Alexandrians are not only very sort of decadent and stuff, but they're very snobbish, aren't they? So they're basically spherical. Yeah. They have a distinctly unprogressive attitude towards foreigners. Yeah. And physical deformity. But he's murdered.
亚历山大人不仅非常颓废之类，而且非常势利，对吧？所以他们基本上是圆形的。对。他们对外国人有一种明显的保守态度。对。还有身体畸形。但他被谋杀了。
Berenike takes great effect. Berenike gets fed up with him. Gets rid of him. Takes another husband. Yeah. So Rabirius, meanwhile, the banker whom Ptolemy's borrowed the money from, takes great effect gets fed up with him yeah sort of him takes another husband yeah yeah um so uh rabirius meanwhile the banker whom ptolemy's borrowed the money from he he essentially you know he he knows that he's not going to get his money back unless ptolemy's exhibition expedition
贝勒尼基深有感触。贝勒尼基厌倦了他。甩了他。另嫁他人。对。与此同时，托勒密借钱给他的银行家拉比乌斯，深有感触，厌倦了他，对，算是吧，甩了他，另嫁他人，对，对，嗯，所以，嗯，与此同时，拉比乌斯，也就是托勒密借钱给他的那个银行家，他，他基本上，你知道，他，他知道，除非托勒密的远征能够成功，否则他是拿不回自己的钱的，
works so he funds an expedition that is led by a guy called um aulus gabinius and they go you know they go to they go to egypt they um they kick bernie k out um she's executed isn't she executed uh ptolemy takes over again and of course the guy who leads the cavalry on that expedition is a young up-and-coming roman officer called mark anthony yes do we have a uh do we have a section from a from a brilliant new book john's a nice reading yeah gazing out from her window beside her servant girls cleopatra could not take her eyes off them one roman in particular caught her attention a square george shaggy haired rugged looking man who carried himself with the arrogance of a born leader one of her servants whispered that this was the young cavalry commander
所以他资助了一次远征，由一个叫奥卢斯·加比尼乌斯的人率领，他们去，你知道，他们去埃及，他们，嗯，他们把贝勒尼基赶走，嗯，她被处决了，对吧，被处决了，嗯，托勒密重新掌权，当然，在那次远征中率领骑兵的是一位年轻有为的罗马军官，叫马克·安东尼，是的，我们有没有，嗯，我们有没有一段来自约翰精彩的新书的朗读，是的，克娄巴特拉从女仆身旁的窗户向外望去，目光久久无法从他们身上移开。其中一个罗马人特别吸引了她的注意，他身材魁梧、头发蓬乱、外表粗犷，举手投足间带着一种天生领袖的傲慢，她的一名女仆低声说，这就是那位年轻的骑兵指挥官，
all the girls were talking about. Some called him the new Heracles, but his real name was Mark Antony. Now, as the handsome young commander swung down from his horse and removed his helmet, he glanced casually up at the window. For a moment, his dark eyes met Cleopatra's, and he grinned. And suddenly, Tom Holland, it was as though time had slowed to a halt and Cleopatra felt a kind of tremor run through her body, a thrill of fear and danger and overwhelming excitement
所有女孩都在谈论他。有人称他为新的海格力斯，但他的真名是马克·安东尼。现在，当这位英俊年轻的指挥官从马背上轻盈地跳下并摘下头盔时，他漫不经心地朝窗户瞥了一眼。那一刻，他漆黑的双眸与克娄巴特拉的目光交汇了，他咧嘴一笑。突然间，汤姆·霍兰，时间仿佛慢了下来，克娄巴特拉感到一股战栗贯穿全身，那是恐惧、危险和压倒性兴奋交织在一起的惊悚感。
all mixed up together. Isn't that exciting? Is that not exciting? That really is. That is a book for all nine-year-olds to read. Yes. Well, very exciting. That really is. That is a book for all nine-year-olds to read. Yes. Well, very exciting.
全都混杂在一起。这不是很令人兴奋吗？这难道不令人兴奋吗？确实如此。这本书真该让所有九岁的小朋友都读一读。是的。嗯，非常令人兴奋。这确实如此。这本书真该让所有九岁的小朋友都读一读。是的。嗯，非常令人兴奋。
Yes. So the likelihood is that Cleopatra may have seen Antony. Well, she must have seen him. I mean, he's so senior because he's the cavalry commander who has led the charge. Yeah. And as her father is installed back in the palace. So the palace, by the way, we should talk about just one quick word about that. So when we think about the palace, you're probably thinking Buckingham Palace or some sort of stereotypical palace, but it's not.
是的。所以克娄巴特拉很有可能见过安东尼。好吧，她肯定见过他。我的意思是，他地位如此崇高，因为他是率领冲锋的骑兵指挥官。对。随着她的父亲重新入驻宫殿。顺便说一句，关于宫殿，我们应该简单提一下。所以当我们想到宫殿时，你可能会想到白金汉宫或某种刻板印象中的宫殿，但事实并非如此。
It's a huge quarter of the city, isn't it? So there are temples that will become important later on when Julius Caesar enters the story because the battle for the palace becomes very important. So Mark Antony has come in with Aulus Gabinius' men, who are called the Gabinians, and they become players in their own right in this incredibly complicated story. And Cleopatra's father is back in charge. And clearly, she is very much in favor with him because she is not punished as her sister was. So the assumption must be,
它是城市的一个巨大街区，对吧？所以有一些寺庙在朱利叶斯·凯撒进入故事后会变得很重要，因为对宫殿的争夺变得非常重要。因此，马克·安东尼带着奥卢斯·加比尼乌斯的人进来了，他们被称为加比尼乌斯人，在这个极其复杂的故事中，他们本身也成了重要角色。克娄巴特拉的父亲重新掌权了。显然，她非常受他的宠爱，因为她没有像她姐姐那样受到惩罚。所以可以推测，
not least because she's now going to be his heir that she in some way is still being loyal to him and in fact she when she takes her pharaonic title she always describes herself as the father loving goddess or the father loving queen yeah so so she's kind of on his side so so Ptolemy Aelites is back, but he now faces the problem of paying off Robirius, the banker who's lent him all this money. So he comes up with a cunning wheeze, which is to appoint Robirius the finance minister. And Robirius obviously settles in and starts screwing ever more money out so to use your analogy you know tom it's like um you know the british sums that the head of you know the bank of england or something had gone to run the argentine economy yeah in 1890 the the episode we did on maximilian emperor maximilian yes being sent by napoleon the third to get the money that the french had lent
更不用说她现在将成为他的继承人在某种程度上她仍然对他忠心耿耿事实上当她采用法老头衔时她总是称自己为爱父女神或爱女王是的所以所以她某种程度上站在他这一边所以所以托勒密·奥勒提斯回来了但他现在面临着偿还银行家拉比乌斯的难题正是拉比乌斯借给了他所有的钱所以他想出一个狡猾的计策那就是任命拉比乌斯为财政大臣而拉比乌斯显然安顿下来开始榨取越来越多的钱所以借用你的比喻你知道汤姆这就像是英国的英格兰银行行长之类的人去管理阿根廷经济一样对吧在1890年我们做过的关于马克西米利安皇帝的那集节目中拿破仑三世派马克西米利安去索回法国人借出的资金
yeah i think kind of very analogous and as in those the money that the French had lent. Yeah, I think kind of very analogous. And as in those situations, obviously the locals don't like this. And so after a year, Robirius gets kicked out, runs back to Rome. And Gabinius, he's played this key role in Egypt. And so obviously everyone back in Rome is now furious with him, incredibly jealous. And what happens in Rome when people are jealous of one another is that they bring law cases and Gabinius gets convicted of taking bribes from Auletes. He's obviously massively guilty of that. And so the whole thing slightly gets parked. Ptolemy is back in Egypt. He dies in 51. And meanwhile, in Rome, everything is starting to go tits up because this is 51 is two years before Julius Caesar crosses the Rubicon.
是的，我觉得非常类似，就像在那些情况下一样，当地人显然不喜欢这样。所以在一年后，拉比乌斯被赶走，逃回了罗马。加比尼乌斯在埃及扮演了这个关键角色，所以罗马的每个人现在显然都对他怒不可遏，嫉妒万分。在罗马，当人们互相嫉妒时，他们就会提起诉讼，加比尼乌斯因收受奥勒提斯的贿赂而被判有罪。他显然犯了重罪。因此整件事稍微被搁置了。托勒密回到了埃及。他在公元前51年去世。与此同时，在罗马，一切都开始一团糟，因为公元前51年是尤利乌斯·凯撒跨越卢比孔河的两年前。
And the whole Roman Republic is going to implode into civil war. And on rival sides in the civil war, we have Julius Caesar and his erstwhile friend. In fact, his erstwhile son-in-law pompey the great and while that matters for cleopatra is that she she's auletes his heir isn't she yes and with a civil war together with her younger brother a civil war in the roman world egypt is so rich and strategically important that it can't really it's it's very very difficult to stay out you have to pick a side but by picking a side it's a bit like being the liberal democrats by picking a side you kind of you you know you pin yourself to a position and if things go badly
整个罗马共和国将陷入内战。在内战的敌对双方中，我们有尤利乌斯·凯撒和他的昔日好友。事实上，他的昔日女婿伟大的庞培。这对于克娄巴特拉的重要性在于，她是奥勒提斯的继承人，对吧？是的，伴随着内战，还有她年幼的弟弟，罗马世界的内战，埃及如此富有且具有战略重要性，以至于它真的无法——很难置身事外，你必须选择一方。但一旦选择了一方，这就有点像自由民主党人，通过选择一方，你某种程度上把自己固定在一个立场上，如果事情进展不顺，
you know you've got no defense yeah you know that's the end of you basically yeah so so so it's it's it's tricky and treacherous and Ptolemy has left Egypt to to Cleopatra who's about 17 I think at this point and Cleopatra's younger brother who comes to the throne and is hailed as Ptolemy the 13th and he's about what 12 13 yeah and they're probably not even that time I think it's about 11 or so i mean these dates are all very vague it's impossible to be sure something to say at this point is that cleopatra never rules without a male colleague so right the way through she always has a a male counterpart egypt had had female pharaohs before hadn't it hat set shut i know you're much more um up on egypt yeah so she's 18th dynasty.
你知道你就无路可退了，对吧，你知道那就基本完蛋了，对吧。所以，所以，所以这很棘手、很危险，托勒密把埃及留给了克娄巴特拉，她当时大约17岁，还有克娄巴特拉年幼的弟弟，他登上王位被尊为托勒密十三世，他当时大约几岁？12岁、13岁，对，他们可能甚至不到那个岁数，我觉得大约11岁左右，我的意思是这些日期都很模糊，不可能完全确定。这时候要说的一点是，克娄巴特拉执政时身边绝不能没有男性同僚，所以一路走来，她始终有一个男性对口人物。埃及以前也有过女法老，对吧？哈特谢普苏特，我知道你对埃及了解得多得多，所以她是第十八王朝的。
So there are role models. I don't think they would have looked back that far. What about the popularity, Tom, of Isis? Because obviously Isis is a colossal figure in the Egyptian pantheon, and one that Cleopatra embraces. She dresses as Isis. Is that not an image of kind of female monarchy? So Cleopatra comes to power.
所以有榜样。我不认为他们会回溯那么远。汤姆，伊西斯女神的受欢迎程度如何？因为显然伊西斯是埃及万神殿中的一个庞大巨头，也是克娄巴特拉所拥护的。她装扮成伊西斯的模样。这难道不是一种女性君主制的形象吗？所以克娄巴特拉掌权了。
She's 17. She has this young boy who is under the thumb of all kinds of significant players in her father's court. And they are clearly assuming that both of these young pharaohs will be ciphers. And insofar as one of them will succeed to power, it'll be Ptolemy. But Cleopatra has other ideas, and this is why she's such a remarkable figure, because even though even she can't get away with just ruling on her own as a woman, she is someone who is absolutely determined to rule as a pharaoh. So she puts her name first. Her name is ahead of Ptolemy's. She puts her name on coins. She puts her portrait on coins without Ptolemy. And she realizes that there is scope for
她17岁。她身边的这个小男孩受到她父亲宫廷里各种重要人物的左右。他们显然认为这两个年轻的法老都将是傀儡。如果其中一人能够继承权力，那将会是托勒密。但克娄巴特拉有不同的想法，这也是她如此非凡的原因，因为即使她无法仅仅以女性身份独自统治，她也绝对决心以法老的身份统治。所以她把自己的名字放在前面。她的名字排在托勒密前面。她把自己的名字印在硬币上。她把自己的肖像印在硬币上，却没有托勒密。并且她意识到，
her in playing not just the role of a Ptolemaic ruler, but a properly Egyptian pharaoh, because there is all this enormous kind of, you know, thousands and thousands of years of tradition and myth and heritage that she can draw on. And that as a woman, as you say, the great goddess Isis, you know, an object of veneration across Egypt and far beyond Egypt, that if she can invoke that, that sense, that sense of herself as the mother goddess of Egypt, then that will get her popular support across the country as well as Alexandria. And essentially, even though she, you know, she's a very, very young girl, the leader of a country that is absolutely on its uppers in debt to Rome in the shadow of this great military
她不仅可以扮演托勒密统治者的角色，还可以扮演一个真正的埃及法老，因为她可以汲取所有这些巨大的、你知道的、几千年的传统、神话和遗产，而且作为一个女人，正如你所说，伟大的女神伊西斯，你知道的，那是整个埃及乃至埃及远超其边界的崇拜对象，如果她能唤醒那种感觉，那种将自己视为埃及母亲女神的感觉，那么这不仅在亚历山大，而且在整个国家都能为她赢得民众的支持。基本上，尽管她，你知道的，是一个非常非常年轻的女孩，领导着一个负债累累、处于罗马这个强大军事超级大国阴影之下的国家，
superpower, she dares to think that she can essentially revive the fortunes of her kingdom and rule as Alexander had. And it's the most astonishing story. And that's what makes her such a remarkable figure. And she profits from the much broader story that is going on of the Roman Civil War and what will become the implosion of the Republic. And I think that we should take a break at this point. And when we come back, we should look at what happens when Julius Caesar meets with Pompey and then how Cleopatra comes to meet with Julius Caesar. So for most of you, we will see you for the next installment of this thrilling historical saga, which will undoubtedly feature more readings from moving and powerful new histories of Cleopatra. So we will see you tomorrow for most of you. But some of you, of course, will have early access to all the episodes because you're members of the Rest is History Club. And in true
她敢于认为自己本质上可以复兴王国的命运并像亚历山大大帝一样统治。这是最令人惊奇的故事。这就是为什么她是一个如此卓越的人物。她从中获益于正在发生的更广泛的罗马内战以及共和国终将崩溃的故事。我想我们应该在这个时候休息一下。当我们回来时，我们应该看看尤利乌斯·凯撒会见庞培时发生了什么，然后克娄巴特拉是如何与尤利乌斯·凯撒会面的。所以对于你们大多数人来说，我们将在下一期的精彩历史传奇中再见，这无疑将包含更多来自克娄巴特拉感人且有力的全新历史著作的朗读。所以我们明天见，对于你们大多数人来说。但当然，你们中的一些人将提前获得所有剧集的权限，因为你们是“历史的休憩”俱乐部的会员。用真正的
Hellenistic style, we never miss a commercial opportunity. So if you want to join the Rest History Club and listen to all the episodes right now, just go to restishistorypod.com and sign up. And if you don't, we will see you tomorrow. Goodbye. Bye-bye. Thanks for listening to The Rest Is History. For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening, and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com.
希腊化风格，我们从不错过任何商业机会。所以如果你想加入“历史的休憩”俱乐部并立即收听所有剧集，只需前往 restishistorypod.com 并注册。如果你不加入，我们明天见。再见。拜拜。感谢收听《历史的休憩》。有关精彩番外、提前收听、免广告收听以及加入我们的聊天社区，请前往 restishistorypod.com 注册。
That's restishistorypod.com. I'm Marina Hyde and I'm Richard Osman and together we host The Rest Is Entertainment it's your weekly fix of entertainment news reviews splash of showbiz gossip and on our Q&A we pull back the curtain
那是 restishistorypod.com。我是玛丽娜·海德，我是理查德·奥斯曼，我们共同主持《娱乐的休憩》，这是你每周获取娱乐新闻、评论、一丝八卦爆料的固定栏目，在我们的问答环节中，我们拉开娱乐的帷幕，
on entertainment and we tell you how it all works we have just launched our members club if you want ad free listening bonus episodes and early access to live tickets head to
告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚启动了会员俱乐部，如果你想享受免广告收听、精彩番外以及提前获得现场门票的权限，请前往
therestisentertainment.com There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
therestisentertainment.com 本集暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。